Okay, so we have our VLIW backward compatibility quiz.
Let's work on a solution. We had a simple
VLIW that had 64-bit instructions and we were doing
one, one of those at a time and each
of those were equivalent to two normal operations. And
now we want to have a VLIW processor with
four operations per cycle, and the way we want
to do that, while maintaining backward compatibility with the original
version, is to fetch the code and execute two
of those 64 bit instructions per cycle. The questions
is, is this new processor a VLIW processor? The
correct answer here is no, not really. Here's why.
In a real VLIW processor, the compiler tells us
which operations can be done in parallel by putting
them in the same instruction, and then we try
to do only one of those instructions per cycle.
Thus, every cycle we are guaranteed that
we're going independent operations. When we run programs
compiled for this processor. The compiler only
got on these, that the two operations in
the same instruction are in parallel. In
fact, if we have something like this, where
we have a data dependence, the compiler will
put these operations into two separate VLIW instructions.
And put NOPs for the second operation to ensure that
we first do this, and then we do this. If this
processor now is trying to fetch the code and execute
two such 64-bit instructions per cycle, it might easily fetch these
two and try to do them in the same cycle,
thus violating this dependence. So, this type of processor is not
a true VLIW processor because it would have to check
for dependencies which makes it similar to a normal superscalar processor.